I have a look at this and I can see four
terms right so someone has expanded and
they've gotten these four objects cut so
we're going to try and reverse engineer
and try and see if they're a bit that we
can pull out factor it out and there's
ever something nice and all brasses okay
so when you see for a common need to do
is happen when you pageant in the early
examples are nicely ordered for you so
you can see the birth to go together and
the last you go together this won't
always be the case we could really
easily jumble them up and they might not
just sit next to each other
but what we're about to do will still be
the same first in terms what do you see
in public sale earlier to wtr to WT they
only differ by that HMA so I'm going to
factor eight out the 2w which leaves me
with the H off the cake note the side
that's important you've done with the
first pet that's good
one of the ways you will know that
you've done this right is that when you
go to your second pair you very likely
will see something similar
what's it called I can see they're done
- three you here and a minus three you
there again remember watch out to the
side so I'm going to take - threw you
out of each other what does it leave me
with just for this one I'm going to say
positive H because what you took away
they don't need it's gone down what
about here + okay very good
and this was that sort of like oh good
I'm on the right track because we're
going to class questions for you that
will often end up with these market
results should to see if you collected
now here's the thing you've done
whatever factorization
but there's more to go remember how we
said only point out of 2w wander these
both have a minus 3u on them these birds
also have some people becoming mainly h
plus K so I'm going to take that as well
see that it's in common just like the
two w's were in common just like the -
use or in common it's big and awkward
but it's enough agent number Kaiser
Navarre and together our just looked
harder but a visit when we take out the
H plot K what does it leave you with it
and watch out for the sign now you know
you're done so is there anything else we
can possibly do I think it looks like I
think it looks fine however underneath
here and if you've got another if you've
got another co-op what I want you to do
is imagine when I'm changing the
question ever so slightly imagine
instead of this line is got me on yeah
turn the different question and we end
up with this can you write this for me
okay so suppose this set of true W were
taken out in a square and instead of a
minus three view we're taking out a
minus B Square now I can work on this
line just like I did to this the common
factor between these two is H Bar K so
right now front like so when I factorize
that out divide both terms through what
does it leave me on the other pair
brackets is good now in this case in my
made-up question unlike in the original
I can hear it further and this is the
thing you have to ask your factorization
there's many steps to it how far can i
push this is there anything else I could
screen down there you can't squeeze
something else out of this namely this
thing here it's difference of two
squares again right so these I can
factor one more step okay
the h plus K they're just going to hang
out the product theories do anything
after that but this guy you can write
factorize even further okay
a minus B a plus B on behind okay so
this goes like oh hey why is a great
question like a great question I'll
answer that in about 6070 this goes all
the way back to in Year seven when we
gave you numbers like this and said can
you satirize and you would say oh yeah
that's cool I can do that it's like
three times Paige
but then I put you post the question
right oh can I go any further you can't
go any further with this three prime but
you can't go further with this right
what would you get out of this so forth
can I go any further yeah very good
so there's the factorization and just
the same way you can do it you now I've
got asked the questions why why would
you do this okay let me really quickly
show you this is the moment is an
expression the top line how do I know
it's an expression what makes it in
expressions over it it's got an equal
sign right it's not equal to anything
it's just a bunch of numbers in algebra
however if we were in equation we have
an equal sign on it there naturally the
thing you tend to do with the questions
is try to solve right if you want to
solve something factorize forms are
hundreds of times easier to solve then
not factorize forms right if all you've
got is this up here you're just stuck
just trying number down there a good way
of seeing you know what will make this
equal to zero but if it's factor I and
we're about two lessons away from this
one its factorized solving it like it
literally tells you what the solutions
are
once you're in sacrifice before okay so
that's why we're flexing these muscles
said when we get there we like oh it's
cool I've got to school under my belt
factorizes easy I'm good at it
now once that's all